they sorry I don't know how long but
this support I see I feel gives me you
know this needed energy to keep biting
and yeah
well thank you ninja
um great insights congratulations we
will let you rest we just had a
handshake in the Magnus game obviously
as expected that game ends in a drawing
we will let you go uh best of luck on
your game uh second game tomorrow
thank you bye
and there we have it the bailout a 35
move draw in our championship game what
a well-played game prognananda with some
filigree Precision in the end game as
they discuss the position
really impressive Peter I think that
just the Precision with which prognanada
handled that final part of the game
started to feel like Magnus might be
putting some pressure but at the end of
the day a very balanced well-played
Affair lasting just about three hour